tu es dans un camp de jour l'été piège
il y avait des ateliers d'arts
plastiques depuis géométrie terne
macha limonchik en fouillant dans nos
archives j'ai retrouvé une des premières
d'entrevue que vous avez donnée à radio
canada
1993 vous venez tout juste de finir
l'école nationale de théâtre et vous
parler du métier qu'est ce que je
pouvais bien dire de ce métier que je
connaissais pas comment vous expliquez
que ça a débloqué que ça a bien
fonctionné pour vous parce que dans
cette entrevue vous a plutôt nerveuse
j'étais très chic et j'étais quelqu'un
de très très très très gêné avec une
certitude que je ne pouvais pas faire ce
métier là que je n'étais pas la bonne
personne pour faire ce métier de alors
je commande y en a un très bon français
je frottais j'ai toujours ce que c'est
ce que je voulais faire c'était non
j'étais prêt j'ai très apeuré en fait
j'ai bien des scènes avec revue je le
connais pas
c'est un peu énervant je fais ça blanc
par la suite l'hérault se sont succédé
mais tout de même en 2014 avait dit
c'est difficile pour une femme d'obtenir
un grand rôle à la télé ce que parce que
les choses commencent au monde a changé
la télé est un et le lieu je dirais le
plus accueillant pour les femmes âgées
surtout dans les téléromans
mais peut-être que dans les séries plus
lourde
on a une très petite tarte à se partager
à plusieurs actrices et il faut être
patiente
non je crois pas que ça s'améliore
vraiment au cinéma n'en parlons pas au
théâtre était difficile aussi parce que
les jeunes créateurs écrivent pour leur
génération dans les classiques
il va peut-être avoir un rôle de nounou
mais non c'est pas ce n'est pas si
facile que ça on vous voit aussi dans la
série trop à peine dans la saison 2 je
vais arriver dans la prochaine saison
que vous verrez l'année prochaine oui
les gars sont au-dessus du lot de
sentiments
ouais ouais parce que c'est un homme qui
vous adore coeur complètement
complètement j'ai des gens autour de moi
moi j'ai déjà souffert d'une dépression
aussi c'est très lourd c'est très
difficile cdc j'ai beaucoup de
compassion il ya beaucoup de désespoir
et les atouts sade de vies gâchées
parfois de 17,2 et c'est vraiment
important que ce soit déstigmatiser je
sais pas si sa vie comment doit-on
repart le justement juste en parler
toutes les histoires sont différents
cette rencontre vient à plaindre semaine
de la diversité culturelle auteurs
justement comment vous la voyez cette
diversité culturelle je suis très
content de voir tous les efforts qu'ils
font moi je viens du quartier côte des
neiges avant d'avoir des amis québécois
ça a pris beaucoup de temps moi j'avais
j'avais très peu d'amis québécois en
fait des hongrois des tchèques et donc
j'ai baigné dans cet univers là toute
mon enfance et quand je suis arrivé à
l'école nationale de théâtre tout d'un
coup tout est blanc et c'est avec un
immense pour moi et ça fait des années
que c'est mon cheval de bataille
ça a été un choc culturel en fait pour
moi c'est donc ça fait plus de vingt ans
que je manque l'un et je vois que ça
commençait réellement bougé qui est un
réel désir de représenter
ils sont à montréal donc les montréalais
et je suis immensément contenter
reconnaissante que le montrer
[Musique]
pour la saison 2010 et 2019 vous allez
répression théâtre d'aujourd'hui non pas
dans une mais deux pièces c'est tout un
défi ça c'est toujours toujours un défi
toutes les pièces tous les personnages
tous les auteurs toutes les mises en
scène à chaque fois je suis surprise à
quel point c'est à recommencer c'était
par an donc booster cette part on notera
comme ça c'est un mélange d'excitation
de ath ii de peur de vouloir bien faire
de vouloir que les auteurs soient
heureux qui les met en scène soit
heureux
[Musique]
je vous dit que la coupe nous avons
commencé avec vous en tout début de
carrière vous avez aujourd'hui une fille
qui s'intéresse un potard oui quels
conseils donnez-vous d'en voir d'en
rêver si c'est ce qu'elle veut faire
toujours plus tard mais d'en rêver je
crois que ça aviv la la frustration de
ne pas en faire à vivre le désir très
fort parce que ça prend un immense désir
puissant pour faire ce métier et je
crois que la tante va être très bonne
la fin du match et c'est un plaisir pour
moi aussi c'est
[Musique]